hello everyone it's the last round of
the world rabbit championship and the
situation is quite intense Carson and
Anand are tied for the first place and
Carson faces Alexander Greece took on
board one well I don't know if it's
really board one since Carlson has his
own board that he's playing on but
either board one on board - and Anand is
playing against cousins old nemesis boo
on board - or could be board one either
way and Anand makes a draw with Boo and
move 12 so Carlsen either has to win
this game or he doesn't win Seoul first
in the world rapid championship because
as you've seen Carson lost his personal
game against Ireland so Carson has to
defeat Grisha if he wants to become
world rapid champion so let's see how
this game goes and the cousin has the
white pieces we have Knight to f3 he
starts with already opening Knight to f6
by grace Chuck g3 g6 and b3
Bishop to g7 cousin goes Bishop to b2
and the d6 d4 English to castles Bishop
to g2 and the Knight B to d7 and cousin
castles
we have rook to dat rook to e8 sorry c4
and c6 now Knight to c3 and E 5 and
meters mashenka said in this position
that white it definitely doesn't want to
play play d5 and this is the exact
moment when cousin played the d5 he
plays d5 and meters mishchenko said that
maybe the idea is that unlike for other
similar positions the roof is on eh
instead of f8 so maybe that's the reason
why d5 works here Grisha captures we
have C captures on d5 and now e4 Carlsen
plays Knight the d4 and here comes a III
by grace chook and it's already a wild
position probably the best idea for
Carlson is to play f3 okay this will be
an annoying pawn on e3 but you know the
game goes on at least would have 3 you
stop this Knight from infiltrating with
Knight g4 or Knight d4 t4 if possible
but after e3 Carson played f4
Grichuk immediately jumps in with Knight
to g4 now he has some unpleasant ideas
of Knight coming to f2 and Carlsen plays
Knight to see - probably with
the idea of attacking the e3 pawn and
well Knight to e4 does seem like an
interesting idea here you protect the
the df2 squared the knight can't jump
you have to also we attack the d6 pawn
the problem is Greece Chuck has nice to
see five and now this night will get
exchanged for this night and the night
to f2 is coming either way and but if
you capture on c5 then D captors on c5
and you lose a piece if you move the
knight you lose the bishop on b2 so
after 94 night the c2 was played by
Carlsen and now comes Knight d2 f6
better to leave this move for later as
they always say the execute the threat
is stronger than the execution and here
Carlsen played Queen to e1 and it's a
bit of a peculiar move it's hard to say
what the idea is here
maybe maybe after a night - f2 he
thought about playing something like
nice that he want to try and exchange
this Knight but this actually doesn't
work due to a due to a devious tactic
that this Knight to b3
this comes with a would an attack on the
Queen end on the bishop on b2 and if you
capture the night you get E - and it's a
much better position for black so after
this Queen to e1 Greece took place the
Bishop to b5 again the strongest move we
have Knights to d4 and now Bishop to e4
Carlsen captures and Knight captures we
have Knight captures and now nice to e6
there were a couple of moves to consider
here but like I said Carlson has to win
this game if he wants to win Seoul first
place and he goes for the win
knife to e6 now now this Knight is no
longer protected by the rook the knight
jumps to e6 would a simple on the Queen
so the knight pretty much has to be
captured also there's a double attack on
the bishop on g7 so after night the e6
group captures it as captures and we
have Bishop captures on g7 and here if
you play something like King characters
on g7 after Bishop captures only four
it's a perfectly fine position for white
but after Bishop captures and g7 Greece
again plays the the absolute best move
that is night - D - getting the knight
out of the way attacking again the rook
on f1 and now Carlson has to do
something about this Bishop on g7 so
bisher back to be to good issue grabs
the exchange night captures on f1 we
have Queen captures on f1 and there is
only one good move for black here and
the district finds it that is e five you
have to play e5 if you allow D captures
on e6 then this Bishop becomes alive and
it's it will be a bad game for district
so II five and Queen to f3 an
interesting idea by Carson and a good
move now if knife to f2 comes this
doesn't trap the Queen on f1 and here
probably the best move was actually
United to f2 as the night is now
attacked on g4 after night to have to
it's still a better position for
district and good if ship here plays h5
and this is a small inaccuracy that
Carlson didn't take advantage of after
h5 Carlsen had to play Queen to e4 after
this Queen to e4 Queen comes to B for
which the tempo attacks the g6 pawn you
have to defend this after something like
King to h7 now you play h3 and after
something like Knight to f6
you have Queen captures on e3 and white
is okay here there is compensation for
the exchange but after this h5
inaccuracy by Greece chuck colson makes
an inaccuracy of his own and he really
can't afford inaccuracies here as he did
sacrifice the exchange he played h3
immediately and he allowed this trapping
move pawn to e4 now the Queen has to
move Queen to f1 was played and now
comes 92 h6 there you know you could
have considered something like Knight to
f6 or maybe 92 f2 but actually neither
h6 is the absolute best move and is the
only move that gives Greece to the
advantage now you're preventing Carlsen
to push at five also this Knight is now
coming to f5 to threaten g3 to support
III it's a very unpleasant position for
Carlsen
so King to h2 by Carlson and simply rook
to c8 you develop a rook preparing ideas
like rook to c2 maybe to go for the
bishop infiltrating into position and
call some counters this would work to c1
we have Knight to f5 tweenty one tweenty
to e7 and now rook the c-4 preparing a
queen to c3 cross and wants to get
something for for
is exchanged sacrifice rope captures on
c4b captures on c4 and now rook to c8
again going for the c4 pawn and call
some place Queen to c3 now definitely
threatening the Queen to h8 and simply
kink the king to h7 by Grigio we have a
4 B 6 and now Bishop to a 1 preparing
Queen to be to cross and doesn't want
his Queen to be on the same file as this
rook
so a6 Greece chick now prepares b5 and
Queen to be 2 now b5 is no longer a
threat and Carson does offer the c4 pawn
but it you know you can't really capture
it since Queen 2h it will be checkmate
so g5 and when I saw this G if I move I
mean there were a lot of ideas for
Greece trick here do you push h4 do you
do go for the play on the Queen side do
you do maybe try and improve before you
push but grief should actually played
the g5 here and when I when I saw this
move I thought since the Greece trip was
a long time but that doesn't really
matter grace chip is always a long time
when I saw this D if I move I thought
that's that's a blunder I mean simply g4
must win for Carlsen the problem is and
I can't you know I was really amazed at
how good how fast Greece Chuck saw that
g4 doesn't work the idea is that after
g4 you can't really move the knight if
you move the knight Bishop captures e4
with Czech you can't capture because you
get Queen to g7 checkmate
as the knight has moved from f5 so I
really didn't see the idea why g4
doesn't work but it doesn't work because
of H captures H captures and now you
don't move the knight you simply play G
captures on f4 and after G captures
night and f5 you have Queen to h4 check
kink to g1 and now Queen to e1 check
king - king to h2 and now Rock the g8
and there is no defense against Queen to
g3 checked followed by Queen - G -
checkmate whatever you play I mean if
you move the bishop if you for example
captured e4 pawn than Queen to g1 is
coming there's just really isn't a good
move here or even better if you capture
them simply Queen to h4 immediately
checkmate and of course if you play a
slow move and then simply Queen - geez
followed by Queen captures g2 this is
checkmate and it took Greece shook like
seconds to figure out that g5 is
actually a great move
so g5 by Greece shook and here Carlsen
saw that g4 of course doesn't work he
played Queen to be one may be thinking
about capturing this efore pawn if
Greece chook continues on the King says
but Greece took simply calmly plays rook
captures on c4 he grabs the pawn the
rook is not defending the e4 pawn queen
back to be two across and again
threatens Queen to h8 rook goes back and
we have Bishop captures on e4 as there
really isn't a move here Carlson can
play he tries this devious sacrifice to
get at least some counter play he plays
Bishop captures on e4 Queen captures and
now Queen to f6 okay you do you could
have some threats here with Queen to f7
check maybe grabbing the h5 pawn
also F captures and g5 will maybe maybe
do something and again Greece trick has
only one move that allows him to keep
his advantage and that is rough - GA -
that is exactly what he plays F capture
son g5 by Carlsen and we have h4 now
King to g1 and not allowing that pawn to
be captured with check we have Queen WB
one check by Griff sugar King back to G
to Queenie for King back to g1 both of
them figuring figuring out what to play
as they're both low on time and H
captures on g3 and here Carlsen plays h4
the problem with a move like Queen to f7
is that it really doesn't do anything
for example Knight to g7 and now Queen
to f6 okay you do threaten checkmate mhm
mhm sex but simply Queen to g6 and
cousin has nothing here
so after this H captures and g3 calls
and tried with h4 we need to be one
check in g2 again 24 King G one queen
bee one King to g2 and now the district
took the time while he was moving the
Queen around to actually calculate that
Knight captures on h4 was a great move
this comes with check King captures on
g3 and now if Greece Chuck isn't careful
Queen to h6
does come with checkmate so he can't
make a slow
Queen to e1 was played now this comes as
a check and also defends the knight on
h4 King to h3 not Queen to h1 check King
g4 and now Queen to e4 check there was
actually a much better solution that is
Queen to G to check but in time trouble
you don't really you don't really have
the luxury of finding moves like this
sacrifice simply the knight on h4 after
King captures Queen h2 check King g4 now
you capture the pawn I need to King g3
and are simply queen to have to check
you exchange Queen's Queen captures pawn
captures team captures and here comes
Rock a person g5 would an easily winning
end game but after king to g4 ok grace
check played Queen to e4 check King King
comes to h5 and now comes the only move
that actually gives the district still
the advantage that's going to g6 you
have to exchange Queen's King captures
night on h4 now comes Queen captures
Bishop historic in captures Queen Bishop
captures Queen and King to g6 and now
it's both players have four pawns but
the district has a rook against the
bishop and this is an easily winning
endgame it doesn't really matter that
the district is very low on time
King g4 b v a captures a captors king at
4 rook to e8 cutting the King off so the
King can't approach the pawns on the
Queen side Bishop to c3 but now comes a
rook c8 you can't really play a move a
blockading move like Bishop to b4 to go
for this pawn because rough to c4 check
picks picks up the bishop so Bishop back
to f6 worked the c5 King chapter XIII
rook captures d5 King to e4 now comes
rogue d1 King F 3 B 4 and after efore
grisha played rook to e1 and here
Carlsen really doesn't have any move to
play so in this position Magnus Carlsen
resigned the game and I I don't really
know what the final standings are I know
that going into round 15 this is the
last round with the world rabbit
championship Carlson was tied with Anand
with 10 points but if he won this game
since another drew his game against boo
immediately after 12 moves he would have
been the sole champion
but now that he lost this game against
Greece joke I will have to check I will
do another video in in the honor of the
winner and see who the actual winner of
the world rapid championship is so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
and what do you think of cousin's
opening choice in this game I mean he
had to go for the win he had no other
choice what would you have done in this
position so yeah as usual you can check
to my previous videos here I think all
for watching and I will see you soon
with the probably another game from the
world rapid championship honoring the
winner of this wonderful event see you
soon